par ap
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la colonie huttérite de
cristaux spring il en existe des
centaines d'autres comme celle ci un
véritable village religieux où vivent à
l'écart du reste du monde une trentaine
de familles huttérites ici c'est lui qui
dirige cette micro société dont le
quotidien est basée sur la religion
edward cloud saas et le pasteur de la
colonie à la fois guide spirituel et
leaders politiques élus par les hommes
de sa communauté
les huttérites forme l'un des trois
principaux mouvements anabaptistes
chrétiens les plus radicaux ce qui les
distingue des deux autres soient des
amis chez des mennonites c'est le rejet
de la propriété privée originaire de
l'autriche et pacifiste convaincu les
huttérites ont toujours fui les guerres
et surtout le service militaire
obligatoire et se sont posés dans
l'europe jusqu'en russie
ce n'est que vers les années 1870 que
cette minorité germanophone arrive en
amérique du nord
aujourd'hui ils seraient plus de 50000
établi dans les prairies canadiennes et
le midwest américain à vivre en petites
communautés d'une centaine d'âmes dans
ce qu'ils appellent des colonies comme
ici à cristaux spring bien que tout le
monde travaille
personne ne reçoit un salaire
directement il n'y a pas de pauvres
parmi nous je ne possède rien et tout à
la fois lancé world
mais on est bien loin de l'époque où les
colonies ne vivaient que d'agriculture
les huttérites ont la bosse des affaires
la plupart des colonies se spécialise
dans un domaine manufacturier à creston
spring on fabrique t montjoie rapports
et des barbecues qui sont vendus à
l'extérieur de la communauté
à l'heure du lunch c'est à la cuisine
qu'on retrouve les femmes qui en plus de
s'occuper des bambins prennent leur tour
au chaudron puisque tous les repas sont
partagés ensemble en communauté les
hommes et les femmes mangent séparément
et pas d'exception pour les visiteurs
les huttérites crois que la vie doit
être vécu le plus humblement possible
c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison
qu'ils sont vêtus ainsi glenda est une
des couturières de la colonie just mort
est une modestie plutôt élastique diront
certains puisque christophe pin est
considérée comme une des colonies les
plus libérales
contrairement à d'autres colonies les
jeunes de christos ping peuvent
pratiquer des sports ou encore jouer de
la musique à l'école une école située à
même la colonie trop complexe à
confectionner les vêtements chauds sont
achetés à la tendance du moment même les
traitements d'orthodontie son permis et
tout le monde possèdent un téléphone
intelligent avec l'internet au bout de
leurs doigts les jeunes du terril sont
de plus en plus sollicité par les
tentations du monde extérieur
comme la plupart des jeunes filles de 18
ans greta classe a su à vous consulter
youtube et instagram pourtant greta
refuse de porter du maquillage parce que
ça va à l'encontre de sa foi mais quand
j'étais plus jeune ça m'est arrivé de
rêver de voyages confie-t-elle mais ce
n'était que les ambitions égoïstes à moi
affirme-t-elle comme c'est souvent le
cas lorsque les gens décident de quitter
la colonie
[Musique]
on
l'exode des jeunes edward connaît bien
ces trois faits sont quittés pour
poursuivre leurs études ils vivent
désormais à calgary
ici ni l'éducation supérieure mais
l'ambition ne sont valorisés les enfants
d'edward n'ont pas l'intention de
revenir et c'est correct comme ça
croit-il malgré tout la majorité des
jeunes décident de rester de se marier
et avoir des enfants
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que les
huttérites ont su assurer leur survie à
travers le temps
lorsqu une colonie devient trop
populeuse les huttérites de différentes
colonies se réunissent pour en former
une autre
une façon aussi de limiter légèrement la
consanguinité
si jacques audrey charbonneau
radio-canada dans la colonie huttérite
christophe pineau manitoba